I probably get 50 a day of people saying
like can I work for free for you number
one is that if you're going to try and
do this approach you want to go to
somebody who's one or two steps ahead of
you if you're like hey Elon can I get
your coffee for you like Elon doesn't
need you to get his coffee there's this
issue I that I see amongst poor people
that think that their time is worth
something and it's not there's no
shortage of low skilled labor number two
is you want to make them an offer that's
so good that they feel stupid saying no
let's not pretend here like my life is
not better off because you're in it now
your life is going to be significantly
better because I'm in it get this in my
DMs all the time hey I'd like to do this
in exchange for working you know
alongside you no the whole principle of
giving first isn't an offer to give
first it is giving first period without
expectation of something back what does
Chris need well Chris probably wants
somebody to edit and cut his podcast you
don't offer to do that you just do it
and then send it to him and then you
keep doing it and I'll bet you that if
you do that for a 100 days straight
Chris will be like well damn this kid is
like really really hungry he took the
initiative he figured out what I wanted